[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark
seahorse podcast
q and a during a pandemic section of
saturday all right that was not coherent
no but i think actually given when we
started and why we started so far every
single one of our live streams has been
during a pandemic yes if we are too
we should you know
the common understanding of
what a pandemic is in light of that i
think we should
rebrand them
um still alive streams
okay right yeah okay let's let's okay so
we're gonna we've got a bunch of great
questions we're gonna start with um
many
that have nothing to do with
um
sorry i just lost my place uh that have
nothing to do with covet and then we're
gonna drop the youtube stream and we're
gonna address some of the covered
questions
uh but
you just riff for a moment because i
just lost a question i was trying to
find
riff
um
you ever get that not so coherent
feeling when i get sorry i don't know
what to say okay right okay i mean
no you weren't
okay okay so i did not share this with
you but i saw that what what do you
think we can admit that it did not work
yeah attempt to just simply start
riffing
fair enough i've already i've already
forgotten about it
me as well
um this came as a surprise to me a
disappointing surprise and i have not
shared it with you yet um but i will
read it here and then i will uh
show what i have done and we'll see if
you have a suggestion for something else
all right
loved 1491 the charles mann book but
unfortunately man dismissed your book
based on the guardian review called you
evo devo guys who don't consider
archaeological evidence a variety of
ancestral social environments which is
quote inimical to the idea of a single
rigid human nature
and then this person writing in gives
the twitter
the url where this came from and says
thoughts
yeah and i thought oh for christ's sake
so i went you can show now zach um to um
the the terrific charles mann um
tweeting this awful dishonest guardian
review saying memorably tough review of
new brett weinstein heather heinrich
book on how society today doesn't
reflect human nature as it evolved
quote little if it appears to be based
on actual research the science as the
kids say is just a vibe end quote so i
having just seen this just responded
to man's tweet
saying we love your work and recommend
1491 as further reading in our book
indeed it's one of the very first books
that we that we recommend is further
reading in here
um
i say i continue i say to him you have
taken a dishonest critique seriously if
you read our book i'm certain that you
will find much on offer there we destroy
the idea of a quote single rigid human
nature end quote among other things
um
so
what else
yeah it's just wow that's so
disappointing right yeah and i mean and
of course a big you know a big paper uh
we'll publish a
garbage review and some people will only
read the review because that is in part
the point right right but i think the
thing is in man's case yeah right what
he has done the reason that we recommend
1491 and the reason that it was
transformative of our thinking is that
he
challenges the conventional wisdom with
respect to the
peopling of the new world
in remarkable form and so
i fully expect you know as you suggest
that if he engages the material he will
come out somewhere very different and
i'm looking forward to that because
there is a uh
a new synthesis to be arrived at what
happened in the new world
is the greatest story never told i mean
well he i mean
there are many actually practicing
paleoanthropologists
uh and archaeologists but more
paleoanthropologists who have been doing
this work for a while but he is really
the guy who helped bring it into a
conversation that more people were
having right beginning i think was i
can't remember if it was atlantic or
harper's that the first i mean the first
time i ran into his work was in
that i think it was an excerpted piece
from the book called 1491 which is an
article that i was teaching with for
many years and then we both started
assigning the actual book in our
programs um i think the
the point is what i what i find lacking
and it's not like it's absent from his
book but what we haven't done the reason
that the new world is so important
is that the new world because all of the
behavioral evolution that took place in
the new world
is happening in isolation from
everything that happened in the old
world that it is actually the only place
where we have an ability to understand
how humans evolve
that we have looked too much to the old
world
that has biased us too much in the
direction of morphological evolution and
the story that we really need to
understand is the story of our cognitive
evolution and because that takes place
because the story of the peopling of the
new world takes place late right after
the morphological evolution is
effectively all done right and it starts
at a moment when the beringians as they
walked into the new world walked in with
stone age technology they would have had
control of fire they would have had you
know flint knapp tools but they would
not have had
uh written language
mathematics agriculture any of those
things the concept of zero the concept
of zero and those things all uh were
invented in the new world invented or
discovered in the new world in total
independence
the discovery or invention in the old
world sometimes many times right it
allows us to see how human beings
actually function it's the only place
where we're going to get the story right
and well and i mean this point that you
made which i don't think we explicitly
make in the book you know why why do we
start with and then to some degree end
with like bracket the book by talking
about um the people of the new world
is precisely as you say that um
that thank you zach um
that the morphological change by and
large um that reflects who we are as
humans uh was long since over you know
we we do we are not experiencing vast
anatomical and physiological change at
the point that call it 10 to 30 000
years ago right um given the evidence we
presented last week it looks more and
more like between 20 and 30 maybe even
earlier than that
um
that
you know humans already looked human
so what is it that has happened to
change dramatically the impact that we
have had on the planet and the number of
ecosystems we've expanded into how is it
that we have become the ultimate niche
switchers it's about cognitive evolution
it's about uh mental and psychological
and emotional and intellectual evolution
which is no less evolutionary but it
doesn't fossilize no it doesn't
fossilize it is
the genome has offloaded the work of
evolutionary change to the software
layer for a good reason which is very
visible in the new world i want to take
back one thing i just said though okay i
said it's the only place that we can you
can get this story right yeah there's
actually one other place that you can
get this oh i was going to say i mean
you can get it right every place but you
have to look more carefully well you
have the problem is you don't have the
isolation except in the new world which
is necessary to see the story clearly
i'm not sitting in a hole before you say
i'm going to see i'm not going to answer
for you but i'm gonna see if i can i can
i can guess what you're talking about i
have two possible answers in life all
right it's one of them it probably is
i'm not gonna tell you
yeah it's australia yeah okay um yes the
story is not as diverse as i understand
it there aren't as many cultures that
arise um from the introduction but
there's a great deal more richness
culturally speaking than the crude story
that we are told about
aboriginals um so so it is similar in
that way it is similar in that way um i
guess so that was that was what i
thought you were talking about my other
possible answer is actually two and
maybe more depending on how you count
which is thinking about things like
flora the hobbits of flores and dominici
not the hobbits of demonici but you know
these these different
more recently than we would have thought
20 years ago
um hominins
hominins i believe um that show actually
very some very different anatomical and
physiological stuff so you know maybe
that actually makes the opposite point
in some ways yeah i think it's a very
different story i think i mean we have i
guess we have very little
we don't have as much archaeological
evidence from them because they're just
tiny populations right tiny populations
we have a few fossils and one has to
infer much but yeah uh i i do think that
they
tell a very important story i think it's
a different story yeah right the story
the the morphological evolution in those
cases is the story the story in uh the
aboriginal population in australia and
the native american population in the
new world
is the story of human cognitive
evolution and basically adaptive
radiation so why um
why not europe then
you know so i i guess it seems to me
like the new world
and australia because there is one
one place of entry-ish right and so it
makes for a cleaner story there's less
recursion from other populations you
know you don't have a sort of a constant
stream of people out of africa into
australia into the new world the way
that you would into europe and into um
central and and and near asia well i
think that is just it's just sort of the
cleanness of yeah but the cleanness has
an importance
that um is not going to be obvious the
importance
is that because the evolution we're
talking about is software layer
it's contagious
right and so an individual with an idea
dropping in from somewhere doesn't leave
a mark but the idea suddenly shows up
the the isolation of the new world
population and the aboriginal population
in australia tells us that didn't happen
now it will have happened between
populations but the point is you don't
have to worry about where the idea came
from it was organically developed in
both cases and so
the
i guess what i would say is
adaptive cognitive radiation is the key
to understanding humans niche switching
and our
massive diversity
right that's the process that we don't
yet understand and even the fact that we
don't even understand the basics of it
to to the extent that we can't specify
you know as a field we can't specify the
relationship between that cognitive
evolution
and the underlying genetic evolution
right we've punted on that question
um for various reasons some of them
political yeah right and some of them
just based on a confusion about whether
this is indeed a new primeval super not
right but um but the point is you want
to understand how humans work and why
we're so successful the new world tells
that story uh in the most glorious way
possible with it didn't have to be true
it could have been that there were many
inter introductions to the new world and
it turns out there are really two right
or at least that have the modern
implication
two or three
yeah but
yeah less than ten
i think the point is you have a major
introduction you have an arctic second
introduction and the clock starts at a
moment when the morphological stuff is
largely finished and the major
inventions haven't yet been discovered
or at least some of them and so anyway
you can see the whole thing unfold here
good
okay
i kept monarchs for the first time this
summer and witnessed the occlusion of
over 50.
one pattern i observed is that they all
formed the chrysalis and it closed in
the first couple hours of morning
do you have any thoughts on the
selection process and what happened to
the ancient monarchs that emerged at
night or later in the day
so i know very little about the monarch
life cycle and i wouldn't have known
without this question um
that
that ancient monarchs
were
typically emerging at night or later in
the day nor because of the ambiguity in
the way it's phrased is it clear to me
that there was in fact a pattern
right so this so to answer this question
the question seems to hinge on there was
one pattern and now it's different in
captivity and i'm not certain enough
that that is the case to you know to to
want to wade in particularly um but
of course it is true that um
monarchs in captivity are not going to
behave um the same way as they will in
the wild and we in fact
give one example of this in the book
although i can't remember exactly it's
you know it's in service of sort of a
reduction of explaining that a
reductionist understanding of what it is
that we need to do to for instance keep
animals alive will often limit what they
can do in life so is the implication of
the question that monarchs taken into
captivity lose this pattern the way
poison dart frogs lose their toxicity or
is the implication that captive monarchs
have evolved a change
i think it could be either i don't think
the person asking the question david
here is um is specifying uh what so you
know i would say it's not clear to me
that there is a different yeah the cat
just put his paw in my water so that
water has been sullied
um
do i want more sure um
yeah
um
i would like to know for sure that there
is
a pattern in the wild that is that is
not that is different from the pattern
so what we know for sure is that david
here is reporting that he saw a pattern
of uh
of occlusion in the first couple hours
of the morning interesting observation
for sure um what i don't know which is
presumably known is is there a pattern
in the wild of
a different but
relatively narrow time of occlusion the
monarchs typically engage in
if there is then you are asking which of
the two hypotheses or we would then want
to distinguish between two hypotheses
which is that monarchs in captivity have
changed
much as dark poison frogs
um
take them into captivity and they lose
their
toxicity because as it turns out they're
building the
um the lipophilic alkaloids um that is
that is the poisons that they make from
building blocks in their native diet of
ants and mites and there's nothing that
you give them in captivity that will
provide those building blocks so they
over time they at this they already have
their um their color um their episode
coloration but they lose
uh they lose their toxicity um and this
is true for both the dark poison frogs
in the new world and the mantela that i
studied in madagascar um or
right that was one and then the second
possibility was was that a captive
population has evolved a change right
now i'm guessing it almost has to be the
former
i think especially since you know he's
saying i kept marx for the first time
this summer you would you know you must
have captured them
no i mean i i presume that there's a
captive um i mean i i
doubt that anyone
hopefully no one is collecting monarchs
from the wild at this point well but
somebody captured them right they can't
be very many generations down the road
so that would be very rapid evolutionary
change so i'm going to guess that it's
got to be
the loss of the pattern which is almost
certainly going to be the result of some
confusing signal in captivity like it
could be you know the temperature
that there's an optimal temperature
which does not suggest a strict temporal
pattern yeah in the wild it would
suggest a
a empirical measurement that would cause
temperature i mean the obvious one it
could be is just photo period um and
you know actually making sure that
you're
you're mimicking
the photo period of when they would be
doing you know engaging in this in the
wild and really not not breaching that
by turning on the lights at random
moments yep yeah
all right
what are your thoughts on tongue tie
and its effect on like lactation and
speech
i have i meant to look up i have to
remind myself every time i hear this
term which i've heard before what tongue
ties do you know offhand no i'm not sure
i've ever heard the term uh tongue tie
just very quick um
ankyloglossia
from the mayo clinic
is
a condition present at birth that
restricts the tongue's range of motion
so in which the um
what is that uh what whatever it is the
the mid the the medial
membrane that connects the tongue um is
basically thicker or tighter
um oh apparently it's called the lingual
frenulum uh is shorter thicker or
tighter um than it ought to be and
tethers the bottom of the tongue's tip
to the floor of the mouth
so this is something that is i suspect a
modern thing that very few babies
pre-modernity had although i don't know
that for sure and so the question is
what are your thoughts on tongue tie and
its effect on lactation and speech
really all i can say is what i just said
which is i suspect that this is
something
happening in development as a result of
something about what modernity is doing
um to fetuses in utero
um but
what will its effect be on lactation and
speech it seems to me that well
lactation maybe not so much because the
tongue
actually i'm not sure i can't i'm trying
to envision where the tongue is supposed
to be as a baby is attached um suckling
and i can't quite do it so well i think
it's going to reduce the efficiency of
it the movement of the tongue is part of
the suckling
thing yeah and uh
yeah i mean
basically it it can't it can't help so
it's going to disrupt
from something like a minor level to a
major level yeah but i would expect
i mean it sounds kind of serious frankly
yeah now and i think i did i'm not going
to just
continue to read what
what other people have said about it but
i think it is often surgically treated
and
and then you know relatively a
short-lived problem uh if if done so so
sorry we can't say much more about that
i was stung by 20 bees i'd never known
myself to be allergic a week later i've
developed hives it's apparently rare any
idea what variables may be in play also
do you have any good hives remedies
stung by 20 bees
had not known himself to be allergic a
week later he developed hives
well okay so i was sorry i was throwing
the word hives in the context of bees
caused my brain to throw a massive error
but i'm back yeah okay thankfully it did
not cause me to collapse or in other
ways need any sort of assistance but
here's the thing the immune system
is
an amazing dynamic
beautiful system replete with many
vulnerabilities and as i've talked about
before
the major trick that the immune system
does is distinguish
self from everything else right and the
problem is that self-non-self
recognition
when it works is
the key to not being
uh
afflicted with pathogens all the time
but it can go wrong in one of several
different ways you can either
start attacking self and this can
potentially be induced by a pathogen
that is being favored to look more like
self because that causes it to avoid
immune surveillance to lead the immune
system in the direction of reacting to
self in a way it wouldn't have before
you can have the failure of the immune
system to see something
so
hiv for example essentially dug a hole
in the self non self recognition system
that it then
inhabited right it basically went after
the cells that reacted to it leaving an
absence of cells that reacted to it
which gave it
uh free reign you can have the
potential triggering of the immune
system against stuff that isn't you but
is part of how you interact with the
world like your food
so there's lots of stuff and
the the bee thing
is that the bees introduce a toxin to
you which is somehow in a zone where
over reaction
basically allergy is a very likely
phenomenon but the key and i think the
answer to your question which actually
has a lot to do with why
your first dose of vaccine gets a
different reaction than your second dose
of vaccine as we've seen is that your
first dose
alters the immune system same thing with
a bee sting right the b introduces this
foreign molecule the immune system has
its reaction to it and then it may
remember that reaction memory is part of
how the system works right that's why
you don't get the same
pathogen twice is that it remembers so
the fact of having been stung by many
bees
having a bunch of foreign protein dumped
into your system then causes your system
to say oh my god there's a problem with
that protein it's indicative of
something and you know your immune
system isn't a thinking entity so it
can't calm itself down necessarily it
may assume that those proteins were the
result of some pathogen right the b is
not a pathogen but
the immune system doesn't necessarily
know that and so yeah i don't i don't
hear in your answer though an
explanation for why uh why such a delay
would occur uh absent
an additional exposure to the toxin in
this case the bee sting it's not in my
answer but my guess is it's in the
complexity of all of this because what
you have
you know
as we were talking about in the main
podcast
these systems have to have simple rules
in order to work right
you're a being of 30 trillion cells but
you don't have a huge library of rules
it has to be you know you've got 200
cell types or something like that and
so
what happens is
you get the introduction of something
foreign the body takes a guess at what
that is it ratchets up a set of
responses like histamine responses
that cause inflammation they cause the
flooding in of immune cells
etc then you know things unfold over
time as garbage collection happens
macrophages collect bits of stuff
any cells that seem to be infected which
would not be the case in the
beasting instance but in the case of a
pathogen it would be all this stuff
happens and so the point is there's a
trajectory that takes a bunch of time
my guess would be
that what happened is the initial
response to the bees was such and such
and as that response ebbed it revealed
something else
right so something like that
be my guest
hives remedies
right
i don't have any
um
well
you know hives are an inflammatory
response
i would super caution you about
antihistamines which
have very potent effects many of which
are bad uh benadryl turns out
to be connected to dementia
in a cumulative way very bad stuff so
anyway you can intervene but your
interventions will have consequences
that you can't necessarily foresee
um
there are things that are natural
anti-inflammatories like turmeric which
are liable to be much safer
you know if it's
of all of these sort of pharmaceutical
interventions
um i would say in general in this case
topical is a possibility so topical
versus systemic is likely to be somewhat
safer in something like a topical
corticosteroid
while not certainly 100
safe
is likely to have
lower risk than say topical benadryl or
anything systemic yeah
now this
i read because it invokes pink floyd
which as you know i am a huge fan of and
um and know the lyrics to many of their
songs and it provides a lyric that not
only don't i know i don't i don't even
recognize all right so i know i'm ready
i often reflect on the line in the song
pink floyd echoes part one so it's an
early album
quote and no one forces down our eyes
end quote
as others look up
so i i feel a little bit like a playing
name
that tune here like there's not quite
enough words yeah uh to to quite place
it plus it's an early album which you
know i at least have
most people have less familiarity with
than than the latest
barrett album i think so if memory
serves yeah
um yeah i think the the few there's like
three maybe um
or the ones with sid barrett um and then
we know the later ones
once he turned into an orange or
whatever happened to him
um
[Laughter]
in his case is that what he thought had
happened to him that was someone's uncle
um
do you know what to make of this
no i i think i actually don't know the
song yeah i don't know the song either
and uh yeah
okay
um and then this one too
what riff did you wish to share on the
podcast but never found the right moment
wow i don't remember exactly what that's
about so and actually until i read that
out loud i assumed that this was in
reference to something very particular
that we had said and now i think maybe
it's just like a sort of a general is
there something you wanted to talk about
but never found the right moment in
which case this is your moment this is
the moment this is the moment
wow yeah which you know prepared better
for that question sorry baby um yo try
and try again
try again later
all right um
boy okay we have seven more questions
and then we will uh s
drop the youtube stream and i have to
worry it looks like obviously
so okay
okay well in which case uh i think we're
not
we're not gonna go covered um probably
um if we're on youtube because
um because
youtube is not a place for adults
that's right
that's right
which is a perfect segue for the next
question is there an evolutionary reason
for popping pimples and picking scabs
great questions see see yeah yeah
yes totally
yeah why pimples don't pop themselves i
don't exactly know but i mean they do
they do but not always not in time one
has the sense that for a skilled pimple
popper who knows when to do this it is
an enhancement over what happens
naturally and what i would say is what
one finds inside a poppable pimple oh
wow that's where we're going okay what
one binds in there
are presumably
surface pathogens
encrusted in white blood cells that's
what pus is
and so the idea is you your immune
system has correctly
found some bacteria in some pocket in
your skin and it has
encrusted it
and then you are getting rid of that
pathogen um by expelling it into the
world which is
good right so yeah so you want to get
rid of that what you don't want to do is
get rid of that with you know
fingernails that themselves may have
similar surface pathogens on them you
need to be very very clean right you
don't want to get it you don't want to
give yourself an infection and you don't
want to drive it inward right the whole
thing works if you expel it into the
world and um
right so and then with regard to scabs
um i mean this
one of the things that i think of here i
mean this is
the answer to this question has to be
gross i guess let's just let's just go
yeah that's not on us uh that's not on
us it's on uh blankety blank slate who
wrote who wrote this question
[Laughter]
just kind of touched yeah um so blankety
blank slate is is who to blame here for
for discussion here um
i'm reminded uh and i actually haven't
heard this from a veterinarian in modern
times but when i was little and my cat
would get herself into fights because
she was a badass who got herself into
fights and she would get just torn up
and
get these like deep deep
lacerations that would scab over the
veterinarian would say
take the scab off let it you know let it
ooze uh because otherwise you're likely
to get an infection that's deep and if
you keep on
letting it expel what uh what is in
there it's much more likely to not need
further
um
further work from any of us um being
those sort of the veterinary
professionals at that point in the like
70s and 80s um and it did work
right and in general this um this this
is likely to be at least part of the
answer so
let's put it this way
i think
scabs are very often picked badly
picked in error but that the instinct
yes yes yes too early is right um but
that in some sense if you think about
the classic uh
scraped
knee yeah right
classic scraped knee is going to involve
a lot of stuff
you know not
stuff embedded in the skin in the wound
right and you can pick out the big stuff
you know well you're not picking scabs
at that point so that that's
point is you first skin your knee right
you get all kinds of little gravelly
stuff
in there and you will be driven to take
out the stuff that you can find with
your fingers right the little little
rocks and things but there's lots of
stuff below the scale that you could
access it
and
in some sense i mean i do think wound
healing is as far as i know i've gone
looking for
evidence of what we understand it feels
to me like we know very little about
this process and that basically it works
and we know how to
augment it and protect it but we don't
know a lot about the the magic
underneath maybe hopefully somebody will
point us to
some
large uh compendium of information but
the point is
one of the things that is true is as
you
are healing
things are moving in various directions
right cells are
forming uh things are being pushed and
my guess is that that layer of
um that matrix of stuff that makes up
the scab
contains
stuff that has been pushed to the
surface right and so that a process in
which you pull a scab at the right
moment is actually removing things that
need to be or may need to be removed
helping the conveyor belt of healing
happen so i mean i guess
i would just add that there's a um very
valuable and perhaps necessary for
complete healing part of what you do at
the point that you've say gotten road
rash
um that is necessary that you didn't
mention which is sort of yeah you know
use use your fingers use the tools on
you
to get the macro stuff out but then
flush it you know if you've got running
water either from a faucet or a stream
as long as it's it's clean
so as to get some amount a larger amount
of the microscopic stuff that you have
no chance of dealing with with your
fingers and you know and it depending
depending on where you are and what you
have access to and what it is that you
destroyed yourself on uh flushing with
hydrogen peroxide or
or alcohol
it can also be useful depending on how
deep it is et cetera yep but that you
know the the flushing of it will mean
that as the scab is is uh setting uh
there is
going to be less it's less likely that
there will be a lot of things
that need to continue to continue to be
evacuated from the wound yeah although
in both the case of the zit and the scab
yeah part of the point is that actually
your body has a way of dealing with the
stuff if you don't get it out
and it's not so elegant right so yeah it
can wall
it can wall off stuff that can just
permanently live in
your tissue
or it can dismantle it molecule by
molecule
right those aren't nearly so good as hey
that's a macroscopic thing let's just
get rid of it yeah i would also just
point out though that we do something
uh which i think in many ways is
positive
um but that interrupts this whole wound
healing scab formation we humans we
moderns
uh the daily shower thing yeah right so
that has an interface with this that's
most unnatural and so i guess the
question i would have well specifically
the daily shower with soap
soap which um you know
takes away
all of all of the bacterial stuff on
your skin most of which is beneficial
right that's true but also even just the
warm water
breaks apart the stuff so the the point
is just just as in our book we talk
about the
hey if your bone is aligned you might
not need a cast
question
um
there's some ancient way that scabs work
that presumably does not result in every
hunter-gatherer picking scabs too early
but them knowing exactly when yeah they
should actually be pulled off without
without daily showers also the scab is
likely to become hardened sooner and
perhaps then be right you know have a
few have a few iterations more than you
know if you're if you're regularly
softening it with your shower
it's a different kind of a beast right
that's the thing is that we i don't
think we have a good sense of how that
changes things because yeah uh it's it's
pretty rare that you you're in a
situation where you don't have a shower
available yeah
what are the ethical ramifications of
colonizing other planets when there's a
possibility of that planet producing
intelligent life
now
this depends a little bit on what they
mean by colonizing does that mean
sending people named colin or
it's spelled differently would be
sending people named colon
all right
of which there's yeah but if that he's
that's spelled differently too it just
pronounced the same oh okay well yeah
yes now we're deep in it
um
what is the epic problem
i mean
at one level this is this is exactly one
of the themes of the science fiction
book that i that i wrote that is not yet
out in the world um
but i think that there is a really
important distinction to be made at
least as far as i'm concerned with um
life a planet that might already have or
be well on its way towards having
intelligent life
and a planet that could conceivably or
on which some very you know basic
unicellular forms have even been
discovered that um
just i think that our
our responsibilities are different in
those two cases and where you draw the
line is going to be up you know that's
going to be the sort of the
astro ethicist's
domain right not that that's a thing yet
but
but i think figuring out what that line
is as opposed to saying um
any planet could produce life therefore
we should never go there to me strikes
strikes me as an arbitrary line that is
way too and wonder way too much wonder
yeah it's way too cautious a planet that
has no life on it
uh even if it has the potential for life
because it's in the goldilocks zone
whatever right
yeah i mean there's even an argument
to be made for
altering the conditions to enhance you
know sort of 2001 style
but as far as planets that have life a i
think the primary if you found
unicellular or its equivalent level of
complexity life on some planet the
primary obligation is not to screw it up
right
you know even if present technology can
only get you so much of an understanding
of what you're seeing future technology
might get you farther so not disrupting
it so that whatever other example of
life we have is still available to be
understood
would be a huge ethical obligation on
the other hand well then i mean maybe
i i think that you are coming out uh
with a much more conservative approach
than because i think you know colonizing
another planet not that you know we're
of course nowhere close to this
technologically um on you know on any of
the
domains that we would need to be uh but
you know actually getting people to live
and thrive and reproduce and create
culture on a different planet
would surely disrupt whatever
you know unicycle life was already there
yes i also think it's uh
people just need to calibrate their
expectations here it's hard enough to
get a arbitrarily large biosphere
to function down here on earth
and um right you know
in terms of
meaningfully colonizing in an ongoing
form some other planet that doesn't have
uh
pre-existing life that would be useful
and even if it did have life it would be
almost certain to be useless to us in
most regards
um
you know welcome to not nearly complex
enough systems
[Music]
all right yes
um
excellent
okay
uh
oh p.s this is a second part of a
question maybe but um
it says i pre-ordered hunter-gatherer's
guide in june with amazon eu but they
just cancelled
cancelled so sad
cancelled yep that's what it says
nothing to see here
um
what does that even look like canceled
if the book is still being published
that's crazy yeah i don't i don't know
um yeah try i mean uh sorry i've now hit
yeah we answered that question so i
don't see who it is but um
try again and um
if you have a screenshot that you would
send to darkhorsemoderator at gmail.com
that would be useful uh because we're
trying to collect we've got stories from
all over of people having pre-ordered in
june and now saying they're not going to
get the book until november it's the
first time i'd heard just canceled but
for [ __ ] sake
are artificial rock and climbing walls
good
the times i've climbed natural faces
without safety equipment seem more true
and memorable
yeah you know absolutely absolutely and
uh
absolutely the second part of your
question i would say i'm not i mean i've
just bouldered some i've never rock
climbed um with with equipment or
anything but um
i guess
you know if you've got very young kids
and you're in a place with one of these
artificial climbing structures um i i
maybe it's a failure of imagination but
i have not been able to perceive the
harm right um unless you know so long as
you
remind the child at the point that
they're able to internalize this
um there's likely to be
um as much as the designer of that thing
may have tried to avoid this there's
likely to be some regularity in the
thing that you're climbing
uh that you won't find in natural rock
and also some regularity and natural
rock that you won't find there that
they're you know climbing
real stuff
that changed over time due to the forces
out there in the
in the universe
will be fundamentally different and you
will be able to apply those lessons from
natural face to natural face to natural
face in a way that you may not be able
to climb sort of the monkey brain
lessons
from an artificial rock to a real rock
i i think this is true and at a very
extraordinary level and i would argue
it's actually an interesting analog
it's a funny analog for what you and i
say about
so are you talking now
sorry i was just trying to get him to
change the camera oh got it all right
that was
weird okay you were talking and yeah i
was seeing my face right
um
the
thing that you and i say about the
importance to education of engaging
physical systems yeah
artificial climbing walls are physical
systems yeah but they lack a lot of the
advantage of a rock system now the rock
system is a lot more likely to kill you
right it's very dangerous yeah um you
know it really takes a lot of
understanding so i did do a bunch of
rock climbing and the first two weeks of
the course i took involved us sitting in
a classroom reading from a book that
catalogs all of the accidents from every
year and describes what happened and
this is like you having to pass the
written test to get your driver's permit
before you're actually behind the wheel
yeah except the
written test for the driving thing is
not all that useful in terms of being a
good driver the
uh going through story after story of
people who got maimed or died this was
useful
so useful
so and i i suspect now that you tell me
that that this is what primed you to
become an addict of what could go wrong
it in some ways it is the same instead
but you know i mean imagine that it's a
it's a it's a it's like a dry government
document about the accidents right and
it starts with like a list of
contributing factors and it's like you
know
alcohol
no hard hat sleeplessness bees oh god
right okay
you know and so it's like okay that's
like that's the three that you remember
at near the top of the list they were
all different but you could kind of see
the thing unfold you know the person
you know in one of them kicks a rock
that hits the person belaying them from
below on the head and then falls you
know right so anyway you got it is the
what could go wrong rock climbing
edition
um but anyway the point is yes rock
climbing is actually dangerous because
you cannot control for example am i
about to climb into some bees and will i
you know keep my wits about me as i
escape the bees that i can't get away
from nearly fast enough
right so anyway there's that but the
point is the climbing wall
is has the same problem as the person at
the front of the room telling you yeah
you got it or you don't get it yet right
which is
it's a person and so you're sort of
looking through their narrowed eyes and
if the person at the front of the room
is very very good
then that will be somewhat useful but
it's not the same as
engaging a world of real phenomena that
interact in ways that will inform you of
things and that's right
so you know for example if you face one
of these climbing walls
you can be pretty damn sure there's a
way up it
a climbing wall yeah right as opposed to
a rock face a rock face right now you
have a guarantee right there's no
guarantee there's a way out you may know
on the rock face because it may be in a
book and somebody says oh there's a
route over here and there's a route over
there but yeah you come across a rock
face
in a place that you've never been and
you don't know if anyone else has
although what are the chances of that
these days um there is no guarantee yeah
there's no the world the world was not
put here for your pleasure
right but that rock wall was right and
so i think the thing is
the climbing wall rather i'm about to
get in trouble okay with
lots of very fit people but um
the
the rock the artificial rock wall may
very well be good for practicing certain
things i'm sure it is and it's great for
strengthening certain things
um but it's junk rock climbing
it's you know like junk sex and junk
food still a hell of a lot better than
um
just watching videos of people doing it
oh for sure yeah so i have a level story
that i'm reminded of not about um
not exactly on topic but about bees and
climbing um so like i said i never rock
climb but as you know i learned to um to
climb trees uh in the tropics with
uh this guy joe maher mayor i actually i
think mayor is how he's pronounced he's
he's dead now but he was um
in panama uh
when i
was leading study abroad trips there he
was associated with the institute for
tropical ecology and conservation which
is the field station that i based my
study abroad trips there at
and on
one or two maybe maybe both but maybe
just the one so he taught me to he he
had been a print journalist and then
he'd retired in his 60s he became both a
spelunker and a
and a climber and then came to know
tropical rainforests and used his
climbing skills to um to get up into
trees and there was a
he and another guy had built a platform
near the top of i think it was a seba
tree um
about 110 feet up i think if memory
serves uh maybe conflating that with the
one at tippatini but um
and he would and he had harnesses and
ropes and everything and he would he
taught me and then when i brought my
students down he taught us to to go up
and i have some pictures of a few of my
students and i up on this platform and
it's just really extraordinary to get a
view of the tropical rainforest from
from high um as opposed to at
at ground level but uh a story about him
is that with you know at some different
moment with some different students he
was climbing
and not that tree not a tree with a
platform but they were up at some point
and the two students who were not very
experienced climbers
were coming down and
came down through some bees and they
were africanized which means they didn't
give up
and so one of one of them started to get
stung and joe basically this guy who at
this point was in his 70s
incredibly fit but a guy in his 70s
managed to prioritize getting these
students out of the trees um out of the
tree and safe
but he got just
ravaged so that by the time he got to
the ground he had you know dozens if not
hundreds of bees on him you know managed
to get you know scrape them off get into
the waiting vehicle whatever and rushed
to the hospital and spent quite a few
days recovering and you know amazing
that a 70 year old but a very fit 70
year old was able to survive
um that kind of an attack by africanized
bees
but what he had done was he'd saved he'd
saved the people in his care he'd save
the students in his character yeah
that's that's an amazing story those
bees are incredibly frightening yeah
i've had an encounter or two i've always
gotten away from them but terrifying
on the ground yeah you hear you hear
them oh boy yeah it's really frightening
yeah okay
um
apparently i already clicked we already
did that question because i don't see it
here
why do some people not get fat
why wouldn't every human be programmed
to overeat in the presence of abundance
i think those are two separate questions
and so the first question why do some
people not get fat the premise is
some people could not even get fat
provided the right conditions and i
think i think i don't agree with that
premise if it is in fact what the
question hinges on the second question
is why wouldn't every human be
programmed to overeat in the presence of
abundance
and this also the premise ish here is
that
what causes obesity is simply
how much you take in as opposed to
there's a metabolic
there's a metabolic disorder that is
being facilitated by our modern diets
such that
it is possible that you can eat as much
as you want if you're eating a diet
that doesn't have you know the shelf
stabilizers and you know all of the
fillers and everything that you find in
the middle of the grocery store
uh and you might still not get fat and
this you know there's there is growing
clinical and research evidence for this
more refined understanding of what makes
people fat as opposed to um you know
calories taken in and calories expended
through movement
yep uh one answer is that they're trying
to make the rest of us feel bad
another
yeah that's not a very good answer but
that's an answer um
i think
the thing that i want to point people's
attention to is the informational
question
right so what is the right number of
calories to store on your body
that depends on what kind of environment
you live in right so one fact about
abundance is that if things are truly
abundant if your system gets this idea
that food is available whenever you need
it then carrying it around with you
isn't the smart thing to do
right and so there's a sort of lineage
level calculation where
you
shouldn't want to consume calories that
would be usefully spent on somebody else
if you don't have any limit of calories
in the future right if food is always
going to be abundant yeah then then
actually dial it down dial down your
desire for it right because then every
step is cheaper because you're not
carrying it around with you right so
the things that cause
the metabolic syndromes are likely to be
information that suggests that storing a
lot of extra
fat on you is a good idea
right
um
so anyway information
is the hidden feature here and
undoubtedly in my opinion
information early in your life
information that may come in
uh in ways that have nothing to do with
how you've behaved right so hormonal
information that comes in from the cows
that we tried to fatten up in order to
get more for them
at market right that information because
you're a mammal and the cow is a mammal
and the hormones are
you know cross-reactive
may inform your system in ways that you
had no control over it may be that you
know things like dieting send a famine
signal and cause your body to record
uh the hazard in a particular way it
could be
i mean there's one little puzzle that
i've always
thought was kind of interesting which is
how does your body know how many
calories you've eaten
right in other words
the process has to involve something
like you
are measuring with your mouth
the taste of something which gives you
some sense of the admixture of what's in
it and then there has to be some sort of
a feedback after you've eaten it that
gives you an ability to calibrate how
much that was worth so is what is what
you're asking in the short term like how
does it know when to send the satiation
signals right is that okay so not i i
was when at first it was like long term
i was like well there's i don't know
what's in those black boxes but there's
stuff going on in the gut that is
assessing nutritional factors but my
point is i'm predicting that there will
be an interaction between these things
that the somatic experience of eating in
order to do your ancestors the most good
would have to have been connected to a
feedback that says okay
this had that many units of you know
this kind of joy and that kind of joy oh
and that netted to this many calories
and you know this much protein and yeah
so anyway you would get a feedback that
would tell you
the value of what you had encountered
and therefore what to crave properly and
basically we have a chaotic system where
we have way too many foods so we can't
you know we don't get a chance to sort
of assess the value of something that we
have eaten because it tends to come in
some chaotic sequence with a bunch of
other things
and anyway so my guess is we are wildly
miscal calibrated because
there may be like a a
an onboard
measurer uh that is helping assess when
to stop eating when to keep eating etc
that is going to basically have an
impossible time with the diversity of
food that we have in modern times and
not just not just take take out of the
equation
all of the garbage that we're eating all
the non-food molecules that we end up
that most moderns end up eating but just
the fact that you might have turkish
food one night and spanish food the next
and hamburgers the next and spaghetti
and the you know the to the degree that
there's some censor trying to assess how
much was that how much value was in that
um like i give up it's it's too it's too
diverse it's too much
and i would also point out that in a
natural circumstance
this would be connected to a
the term in ecology is optimal foraging
right but that basically figuring out
how best to spend your time in the
pursuit of food
involves a lot of detailed information
right so some food may be very rich in
nutritious value but so expensive to
collect either because it's distributed
in tiny little bundles or the bundles
it's distributed in are really good at
running away from you or they're guarded
by bees
it might be right it may come with
hazards and so the idea is you know
let's say that there's
a patch of [ __ ] nuts and they're you
know five kilometers away which for
those of you who have not read either
nissa or the other amazing book about
the
gong
which the name of which i always forget
but mongongo nuts are actually one of
the preferred foods of the kung fu yes
in fact
i've forgotten
which
person in the book is asked why
they don't farm
and the answer is something like why
would you farm if there's so many
manganese in the world
but anyway if there's a patch of mango
nuts
five kilometers away and it is liable to
yield you know
six ripe fruits
you know per visit
and the question is well how does that
investment of time and that reward
rank compared to
going and looking for kudu right right
um
yep so anyway there's an awful lot of
place for information to improve your
foraging behavior and we are making it
all so noisy that we suck at it and
it makes us fat indeed yes
um
okay well we're just gonna we're still
having odyssey problems sec
oh okay um well
we've already been at it an hour haven't
we
yeah um
[Music]
okay i they're i'm just going to keep up
with the non-code questions and then at
some point we'll switch and maybe just
do a couple
cody ones the national school boards
association has called on feds fbi
homeland security etc to act in a
coordinated manner against crt objectors
it's unsettling
i just
i think actually someone emailed me
about this this morning maybe it's this
person um just ran into this you've
heard about this
i just barely know anything about it and
i think i have to i have to look into it
more and i think we may be we may talk
about this next where i guess not next
week but next episode in the meantime
yeah let me just say
the
there is a kind of
bloodletting
that happens
where
one settles upon witches and then one
hunts them
and
there is something going on in our
system where we are having
uh
a
an ongoing discussion about who the
worst witches are
and in what ways we might properly
punish them yes and
you just gotta step back and look at
this and say really
we're gonna do this to each other again
right did we learn nothing from history
that's what's going on and so you know
crt objectors is a pretty good
um
measure of willingness to confront
bad thinking
and if you're involved in selling bad
thinking or wielding bad thinking you
might want to find those people and get
rid of them which is exactly what
happened to us at evergreen and exactly
you know the point was that well of
course it was the evolutionary
biologists who
were
teaching about
race and sex and all of that in a useful
way of course they had to go because it
was really inconvenient for the garbage
narrative that was necessary for the
takeover yeah yeah we were critical
theory hesitant weren't we
you better believe it
what are the evolutionary advantages
behind learning a new language love the
book
um
i would say being able to communicate
with people who speak that language is a
[Laughter]
oh man it's so good
i so wish i was good at this
right um i don't actually remember um
drew schneiderler our research assistant
and friend and former student research
assistant for the book
um
uh said at some point i think we may
have left it in as a footnote in the
book i can't remember um
said you know there's such a such a push
right now um to um get kids to be
bilingual young because we know that
there's this uh
critical period during which picking up
a second language is much much easier
once you have a second it's much easier
to pick up a third fourth of fifth etc
and certainly it's one of the ways that
i have long considered
our parenting suboptimal is that we did
not you know we tried ish but neither of
us ourselves having fluency in a second
language
we did neither of our children are
bilingual
and uh i you know i certainly assumed
before we had children that at the point
that we had children we would do
everything we could to to make that
happen it didn't happen
and uh
drew said
you know
what about the trade-offs like no
we never hear about the trade-offs it's
just it's just promoted as obviously
this is a good thing
uh and it seems like it's a good thing
it makes the world more accessible it
makes us all able to reach across more
more
boundaries that seem unbreachable if we
can communicate with people uh with whom
we don't share one language but we do
share a second
but might it not make you know might
that generalism make you
maybe somehow a little bit less deep in
your home language in your native
language
it's possible
yeah i don't discount the possibility
that there are downsides my guess is
we're so far from the efficient frontier
that
the downsides don't manifest it's so
much upside yeah that uh you're just
it's it's well worth it even though
a a very efficient system would reveal
that of course it does have costs it
can't not yeah um
but yeah what the advantages i would say
are
i would say it's an extension of the
advantage of travel itself
right people who have never been
anywhere else
are in a much worse position
to
know
what the world is yeah right or what
they are what their own culture is
exactly everything about themselves you
have to you have to find those things
out through interaction and of course
those of us who have figured them out
at least are in some position to know
that we're limited because of all the
cultures we haven't seen but we can at
least extrapolate to what might be there
[Music]
the thing about language
is the better you are at a language
the better positioned you are to look
through the eyes of somebody who speaks
that language natively
and the more people whose eyes you can
look through the better you understand
what the human experience is but if all
the eyes you look through well are
people
with whom you share a native language
then of course you'll you can get a
pretty good sense of you know what
english speakers
are
but it you know it has a it has a
not only a limit but a bias
yeah you're biased in the direction of
uh things that people who speak that
language which you know of course many
of them will have shared history of one
kind or another so it is it is
profoundly limiting but i think it's
basically an empathy
limit yeah
good uh jason asks why am i bald with
bad teeth when my brother is perfect
thanks
um
i feel like jason probably did something
to deserve this
right i actually blame the brother
oh okay not quite sure why but i think
somehow
yeah perfection is always suspect um
so suspect yeah yeah um well look the
simple answer
to the extent that there's any truth at
all on your story right
and that you are indeed full siblings
has to do with the
edit on the genome that each of you got
um
yeah and you're right so i mean in both
in both senses right like the particular
you could be
anything from uh an exact genetic copy
of your brother even if you're not twins
to actually sharing zero percent um by
common descent depending on what half of
your mother's genome you've got and what
half of your father's genome you've got
it's much more on average or 50 related
um by common descent but also the edit
at the epigenetic level from you know
through development
right well i mean i meant the the edit
that you were describing the genetic
edit yeah um which it just usually isn't
edit usually isn't the word that's used
there which is why i thought it was
worth yeah spelling out no i mean
well okay
there are two things in play one is the
siblings full siblings are 50 related on
average but it can be anywhere from zero
to a hundred right um
but
to the extent that it is actually very
likely to be near 50 percent
what 50
uh is right
potentially
radically altering in terms of how
similar you seem now my guess about this
brother knowing very little about him is
that he's completely insufferable
no doubt and you wouldn't want that so
in some sense i think yeah
yeah totally yeah
okay uh could you speak about the
evolution of binary thinking when it's
useful and when it goes astray
thanks so much
i think you need more categories there
there are binaries in the world sex is
one of them and then there are a lot of
things that are not binary but it's
easier because categories are useful and
many categories are real and
even many real categories have fuzzy
borders and it's hard to both keep in
our heads category but fuzzy borders
therefore category real category real oh
boy what happens at this interface
between them
reasonable people might disagree about
which category it belongs in yeah and
you know i would say there's a larger
principle here
um
which i used to i used to say to
students which was there are lots of
things that contain a very important
truth but you need to be very careful
not to overly fall in love with that
truth because it will obscure some other
truth so like
uh
you know ants and hives are an organism
right
an ant nest
is both very much organism-like you have
to see that in order to understand what
it is but it's not completely true
either and so
um because you have to be able to hold
both things
and not
i guess the point is categorical
thinking is occasionally exactly what
you need and more often than not it is
uh
more confusing than it is helpful and
being able to
facultatively be categorical is the way
to go yeah
okay uh zach you want to drop the
youtube stream and you'd it's
okay well maybe
okay well there's actually one question
here
um
that just came in
um
that we will answer as the last question
sorry we're not we're not going to
address
the coveted questions on youtube
because
we're because it's not a place for
adults that's why it's not a place for
adults so we're going to answer this one
more question here today and then we
will see you all in two weeks
what do you think and i think we
actually already addressed this at one
point but let's let's do it actually we
should just clarify that so the people
who have filed these questions don't
think that we are ignoring them the
problem has to do with the odyssey
stream not being reliable so we can't
just go there we would answer them
yeah and in fact i'll go through um
after we're off and
forward to our next stream those
questions here that i think we really
are going to try to get to next time on
odyssey only because it's clear that um
that we can't have those conversations
on youtube
so final question for today what do you
think about people voluntarily
submitting their dna to services such as
23andme or ancestry both of these
companies are now either publicly traded
through
me or blackrock
there was a recent veritasium video
so i don't know about that last part
and really publicly traded or not
uh you and i have been concerned about
these for a long time and you know as
they were becoming popular
we were encouraged to submit our dna to
them and and did not yeah i think uh
a they're not as useful as you think and
b the hazards are many and hard to even
fully define
um
yeah we can't know what all
um
what all might be done you know dis
collecting all those data and using them
in a disaggregated form so that no
individual id
um was possible is one thing um but i am
not aware of any assurances that that is
the limit of the use to which those data
might be
given i can't even figure out what the
right verb is there
put thank you put
and i mean i guess maybe let's just say
a word or two about the first part of
your answer which is it's actually not
clear how useful they are that this this
is one of these things that promises big
because it feels like well it's your
genes it's your genetics and we know you
know we've got the human genome everyone
remembers the human genome project from
what like the late 90s early on it's
like we've got it
and um it doesn't mean as much as we
think it does
and
uh there are lots of things that will
hide about our ancestry in places where
we don't even know to look yet and so
you know obviously there are things that
are revealed by these uh by these
services but it's really not clear what
the
well really either either the accuracy
or the precision are on them
yeah i mean even if they are accurate
and precise it's not clear what it means
that's the problem is that you know the
nature of
uh genetic identity is that it is
quickly atomized into a population and
therefore reading
meaning into
ancestry it's an interesting curiosity
if i could do it in complete safety i
might as well although pretty sure i
know that yeah we've talked about this
before like i think in your case it's
not very interesting you're not much of
a mutt no all right i'd kind of like to
know yeah
for me yeah totally
um
anyway
all right that's it that's it
um well i guess that's it i guess that's
it we can't we can the odyssey stream is
not working
i think we will given that it's failed
multiple times i think it's a mistake
we'll stop we'll stop here for today and
we'll hope for um
for two weeks from now we will be able
to do that and we'll devote some time
we'll plan to devote some time not just
as an afterthought in the q a to just
answering questions
um on odyssey for adults
all right so
um thank you for being with us consider
finding a hunter-gatherer's guide in the
21st century
available
some places that books are sold um but
it's supposed to be available everywhere
that books are sold the audiobook is
available um but really the hardcover so
the audiobook
we're pleased with and we read it and um
and people are really enjoying it but it
doesn't have
the references and it doesn't have the
recommended for the reading and it
doesn't have the glossary
and there's at least one more thing that
it doesn't have um
so
it's not the complete but you know it it
it could give the sense of there's a lot
of claims that are not actually you know
really fully referenced in in the book
and if you're the kind of person as i am
who when they read something interesting
often wants to follow that and make sure
that it is what the authors claimed etc
uh the hard copy allows you to do that
in a way that the audiobook does not
um so if if you want it keep looking
well be persistent there's keep looking
there's also
they don't charge you
until they send it yeah order it on
amazon and um
we know that books are in the pipeline
so presumably if you order it it will
come at some point and probably sooner
than they say based on how many books we
know are headed in the direction of the
and we have actually heard um a few
anecdotal stories to this effect that
they were told people people who had
pre-ordered in june were now told they
weren't going to get it until november
uh and then uh received a copy this last
week so
um so
so place an order if that's what you
want to do and you may well get it um
before you're being told you will
in other
news uh your patreon conversation is
happening tomorrow
we have um
we are going to have some new
merchandise after many many months
without any some welcome to complex
systems
shirt or shirts coming soon
so the store where you can get those
things is at store.darkhorsepodcast.org
if you want to read about seahorses go
to naturalselections.substance.com
and other things
and
and
find us on youtube and on odyssey and
be good to the ones you love and eat
good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you